what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the joint it's wednesday the
8th of december the joint is sponsored
by liquid iv i love this stuff if you're
having a boozy holiday season and you
need more hair of the dog in the morning
get yourself some liquid iv adding a
stick or liquid iv to 16 ounces of water
you shake it up it'll hydrate you fast
and more efficiently than water alone
let me tell you something man when you
eat edibles it dehydrates you
okay that's where liquid iv comes in for
reals it's healthier than those not
those sugary sports drinks no artificial
flavors
and preservatives i love the tangerine
it's made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan gluten-free dairy-free and soy
free let me ask you a question you ever
go to vegas and get [__] hammered
in the morning you can wake up in vegas
and order downstairs and they'll come
and give you an iv to your room to get
your tip top magoo after i drank like
one or two of these at the gym i
realized it was the same thing
their support and frontline work is
liquid iv liquid iv has donated to
hospitals food banks and veterans 11
million servings donated and counting
but besides that it's a great product
what i do is i drink my pre-drink then i
fill up another big container i add the
liquid iv and i take that to the gym and
i'm drinking from it as i'm working out
let me tell you something my soreness
has disappeared so what i'm gonna do is
this just for your listeners of the
joint only grab your favorite liquid iv
nationwide at walmart or get it
delivered like i do get 25
off when you go to
liquidive.com use code joey so let's say
you want to drink a lot liquid iv or
belly out i'm going to send one of these
to bertrand let's say you work out a lot
liquid iv will help you so you won't get
that sore and dehydrated while you're
working out i love it so do me a favor
go to liquid iv.com right now use promo
code joey
at checkout and liquid i veal take care
it's a great drink i love the tangerine
and i really dig the passion fruit so
give them both the shot if you like the
passion fruit give that a shot too but
liquid iv is tremendous from the heart
of jersey the joint is also brought to
you by c b d
line you know what i like about cbd line
they're always growing i talked to the
guy yesterday my man andy over there
they're making a cbd gummy with
melatonin and delta not that's what's
going on down there with cbd line let me
tell you some cbd line has been great
to me for about three to four years now
and they're going to be great to you too
whether this is the way you start off
the new year you ready the best product
get the tincture the 1500 milligram
tincture start that january first and
make your 2022 even better than what
it's gonna be they got bath balls they
got cream they got the icy cream they
got gummy bears they got the reefer you
could smoke however you want to get cbd
into your system cbd lion will help you
go to cbdline.com read the third-party
lab results and whatever you order i'm
going to get you 20 percent off plus
free shipping to your house no getting
it at the gas station none of that mumbo
jumble
cbd lion.com pressing code joey j-o-e-y
and get 20 percent off your order the
joint is also brought to you by
draftkings listen you all need some
extra scratch before the [__]
holidays of course you do and draftkings
is here to make sure you have a green
christmas in more ways than one we got
ufc this week you got college football
you got college basketball you got mba
and you got the nfl and you're still
sitting there looking around going how
come i'm not winning any [__] dough
new customers can bet one dollar on any
team to score and you can win 100 and
free bets it's that simple you're always
a winner with just one point scored i
love uh draft kings last night i had the
under i also uh monday night i also had
[__] buffalo i thought buffalo would
cover the three but i was wrong but i
still went on the under they got a
social network they got live dealers for
you guys that like to play poker
blackjack baccarat go to sportsbook.com
right now
if the sports books not available in
your state draftkings also has a
draftkings daily fantasy sports contest
draftkings has given all new customers a
free shot at millions of dollars in
total prizes this is [__] insane
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
you can withdraw your cash whenever you
want so download the draftking
sportsbook app right now today use promo
code joey throw down a dollar on any
team to score and win a hundred dollars
in free bets if they score you score
with promo code joey this week on
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nfl you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania west virginia colorado new
customers only minimum 5 deposit with a
dollar wager required
one per custom only don't [__] with me
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details
now if you got a gaming problem go take
care of it 1-800 gamble we all got
problems but if you're ready to rock
let's head over to draftkings download
the app and let's win some [__]
guitars all right let's get this party
started tip
top magoo
[Music]
hey how you doing
come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday december the 8th i'm a
little discombobulated today
don't get [__] married sometimes huh
don't get married guys because uh
it's a [__] beauty from time to time
but it's a beautiful day to be alive man
our guest today is jimmy florin team
we're going to talk about this new
comedy special
that's getting released on monday you
know i uh
i moved here last [__] year and
i've become friends with jimmy and i'm a
big fan of his
in more ways than one
jimmy florentine's a single dad you know
he [__]
he has this kid a couple days a week
that's something i could never do in my
life
when i see what jimmy does and he's got
a deal
with an ex-wife which is very tough uh
two families it's uh
it takes a lot away from me when i look
at jimmy i think about my family when i
was younger not my family today but i
think about
my ex-wife and my ex-daughter
because she is my daughter what am i
going to say daughter for
but it's just really funny how
it's a hard combination
it's hard it was hard for me to be
married and to do comedy somebody's
always suffering
you know i'm always missing a gig or my
wife is
missing me on a sunday or friday or a
thursday
somebody always [__] suffer now think
of having
like a divorce like for me guys listen
when i got separated i can handle the
little stuff but once i was separated
for four years and i realized how much
work went into it
calling back and forth
[__] going back and forth with
attorneys if you ever had to deal with
an attorney you know that's a [__]
nightmare also i don't wish on anybody
but once the divorce is over and you get
your child and you
make uh dates to get you that's a
[__] nightmare too
because now you're stuck with those
things you know every week like you
either have your child monday through
wednesday or wednesday through [__]
sunday or thursday friday saturday so
you can't work on those days when you
have a child unless you have a [__]
huge family i didn't have those i didn't
have a huge family or anybody to [__]
help so for me
when i see like jim florentine or josh
wolf
you know josh wolf for years i was doing
comedy in the early 2000s
josh was one of my best friends and i
sat there as he couldn't do anything you
know he couldn't go on the road like i
did he could do spots during the week
and stuff like that but he was busy
raising a family
and i would see what the sacrifices he
would [__] make every week and i had
so much respect for josh you know even
until today i love josh wolfe with all
my [__] heart because
i know what he sacrificed
he raised three kids
two that wasn't
his and at the same time did comedy at
the same time so you know made peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches would use to
deliver to keep his [__]
his family you know fed you know i look
at somebody like jimmy that gets concert
tickets thrown at him because he worked
on the metal show for all those years
he's on aussie's boneyard he you know
he's doing all these things to put a
life together and on top of that you
gotta do [__] comedy you gotta have
comedy in there and get on a plane and
call and miss games and you know what
man he does it
like it's second [__] nature so i
respect those guys
with all my heart you know what i can
never do it at least i'm [__] honest
the first time i got to call my ex-wife
and
you know argue not argue but just talk
about because it always becomes a
[__] argument just to call them up
and say listen do you mind thursday if
you drop them off at two instead of
three oh my god why
how come you know i have plans it's a
[__] nightmare
just being in that situation if
anybody's in that anybody has a baby's
mama
it's [__] rough
it's rough man
you know i love my wife i really do love
my wife you know we all love our wives
if you're a woman you love your husband
i'm sure you want to kill them from time
to time you know i want to stab my wife
once a week whatever
but i'll tell you what man this is why
i've held on to my wife for so long i
got to be honest with you i was very
picky after my divorce i got beat up so
bad if you've ever been to a [__]
divorce
it's uh
it's mind-boggling on you you know
besides losing your furniture losing
your money
having to sleep on a floor for [__] a
year or two to get back i mean we listen
don't get me wrong i i'm always for your
happiness
you know sometimes we get married for
[__] all the wrong reasons we get
married too quickly we didn't you know
it took me nine years
to marry poor [__] terry
and i knew after five years
that she was my wife but it took me
another four years to do it because
it had [__] destroyed me so long i
was so [__]
anti-marriage i always anti everything
you know one thing i don't like telling
you guys and like i said
the only way for me to make a podcast
work is to come out here and lay
everything on the [__] table for me
that's the best way to make a podcast
[__] work is honesty you could have
lights i could have people pop popping
up here while i'm talking i can have all
these smoke and mirrors but the only
smoking mirror you can't add to a
podcast is [__] honesty which a lot
of people don't do i remember before
mercy was born maybe three months before
she was born
i was at a restaurant called a habit
with my wife
i don't want to drink on mic so all
these people's ears you know these half
of [__] fruitcakes will email me for
a week now you drank water during
in my ear you busted my [__] earphone
for all you guys that think i got a
license [__] i don't have lice i got a
dry [__] forehead from the sun
hitting it i'm losing all my hair so the
sun hits it so i get little [__]
suntans on my ball scout if you look at
my head from behind it's just three or
four hairs left i'm just holding on to
dear life i don't give a [__] i don't
give a [__] if i look like benjamin
franklin or whatever i'm just telling
you guys when i scratch i got no lice
it's just that [__] my head is itchy
from being having a dry scalp i've used
head and shoulders that [__] don't work
if you can see i got no [__] dandruff
that's why i always wear something black
because i want to check out you know
does this [__] guy have dandruff but
no i'm i got a nice conditioner for my
hair anyway
but you know when i was when i got
separated and
i went through that [__] towards 1990 i
said this wasn't me i'm
i'm not working towards anything
at least you know i knew that
i knew i wanted to be her father but i
knew i'd never be her father like i
wanted to
so all that [__] with kids and stuff i
would i would have got listen i would
have married you
but i don't want no [__] kids
but about three months before mercy was
born we were at uh
we were at the habit and we were just
talking about things and i had something
that was bothering me i looked at my
wife terry and i go listen
terry
i got burnt so bad
about my first kid and my wife i i don't
know
i mean i can't believe i said this to my
wife i'm telling you guys so you know
where my head was at even while she was
pregnant
i was a little standoffish i was like
well i'm gonna make her happy
but how happy am i gonna be with a
[__] kid you know like do i want to
go through this again
what if she doesn't like me after she
has the kid is she gonna yank her again
am i not gonna
am i gonna be an old for two [__] dad
is this gonna be the [__] case am i
just the [__] kiss of death with
dad's
so i said to him once at the thing i
know when this baby's born i really
want to keep it to a minimum i want to
be her father but
i don't know if i could deal with all
that again she got really upset and you
know she told me that night that she'd
never expect me to say something like
that but
that's what my head was i didn't mean it
for many of my heart or anything i've
always loved [__] kids i just didn't
know
that's how hard my first marriage was on
me that i didn't know
how i was even gonna [__] handle that
but you know as soon as that child was
born i took a look at that child and i
was like [__]
i gotta strap a [__] pair on and be
the best i could be
and look she's about to be nine
in january and uh i'm very proud of
myself that i've kept it together that
i've been a good dad i've actually read
articles on how to parent something that
i thought was [__] [__] who needs
to read a book i'm parroting i even
read a book at night i read a bunch of
articles on being a father to a daughter
you know what to expect i just wanted i
wanted the boundaries to be correctly
and i would have done the same thing if
i would have a boy it wouldn't have
mattered to me you know i wanted to get
away from that old
parent thing to how my mother [__]
raised me without parenting she parented
me okay you know she did a good job but
not the best job i wanted to do the best
job and i feel now that uh
all that fear i had was getting married
and all
it was just from getting blindsided on
my divorce but you know what nine years
later 21 years later
you know nine years from my daughter 21
years of us being together and 12 years
of us being
our anniversary for being married
you know we're still here and i'm doing
great and uh i'm a great dad and i'm
really [__] happy about that i was a
great husband the first time i got
married and i was a great dad i just
didn't have a [__] chance the first
time i got married i wasn't ready you
know you're never [__] ready that's
why when people get married in their 20
you're like what the [__] are these
knuckleheads doing and some of them make
it work me
it didn't work for me it took two
marriages for me to make it work but i'm
[__] happy
but when i see somebody like jimmy
that's doing such a great job with his
son
he's doing comedy he's parenting he
works he's got a family
it just uh lets you know how proud i am
of jimmy and uh
how let down i am by myself that i
couldn't [__] do that you know trust
me i don't want to get divorced i don't
want to learn how to be a single dad i
don't want to do that i couldn't handle
it
but uh
it's great to know that i got a second
chance of being a dad and i covered the
[__] spread you know so
with that further [__] to do
i'm feeling good i'm looking good
uh smoking you know i'm saying i'm off
the [__] uh
taper on saturday at all lens i did a
great job on it no cheats i'm tip top
[__] magu what else can i say
now it's time for jimmy florentine stay
black i love you
welcome to [__] joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening jimmy florentine what's
going on zooming from six houses away
[__] it we gotta watch the [__] coven
what's happening
it's that and plus we both know what
we're we have no idea what we're doing
technically so no it's just easier
if i had to put two mics up and cameras
and [__] it'd be all over but the
shouting it'd be like that little
rascals when the
soundboard blew up
with the dude with the afro and the hat
kept going [__] tremendous how are
you today my friend i'm good man
everything's great game last night
double header
the kids played great championship it's
great to do things like that on a monday
night just to do something different you
know
yeah my kid playing basketball it's it's
great just great just watching your kids
play i know your door to play softball
too it's fun just going into the games
and hanging out as a parent yeah you go
you talk to the other parents god
[__] knows what they do
they lose their mind a little bit but
last night i had the night from [__]
hell
so i leave you
i come home
my wife texts me she says she's gonna
run a little late because the girls are
still practicing i go on no problem
i go in the kitchen i get my chicken
cutlets and my mashed potato and i'm
sitting at the kitchen table
and i hear meow
meow
meow and i'm like great it's gonna be
all right you know that's it great it's
gonna be fine i didn't know where the
[__] she was
i thought she was under the dinner table
where her bowl is so i'm like i didn't
even look
i go to [__] put the dish in the sink
and i hear meowing and i'm looking at
the cabinets i'm looking under the sink
i'm looking at the tea cabinets i can't
find this [__] cat i opened the
refrigerator because
i had a cat that went into the
refrigerator once and was in there for
like two hours meowing and [__]
i'm sitting there and i'm hearing meow
me i open up the refrigerator he comes
walking out like how you doing it was
just a minute [__] hilarious this cat
so i open up the [__] two doors
refrigerator no cat i open up the
freezer no cat
and i'm like where the [__] is this cat
and i hit meow meow
and i go behind the refrigerator and i
see that there's a can he [__] fell
she's one of these nosy [__]
that likes to walk around and she fell
so my wife wasn't home so i had to pull
the [__] refrigerator out
by myself i had to [__] pull it out
like tarzan
and then she wouldn't jump on the
[__] counter so i had i'm telling you
i had to go to a chiropractor this
morning
get her out on the counter she's [__]
me out and i had to put push the
refrigerator back
what a [__] nightmare never ends at
the diaz residence but i love it that
was my [__] night
i know i got a text from you because
you're going to come over and watch
monday night football like the cat stuck
behind the refrigerator i'm probably
gonna have to pass you couldn't [__]
believe that like i just could not about
20 minutes i'm looking for this [__]
cat
20 minutes i'm hearing meows i'm
thinking that [__] maybe i ate one
too many edibles the night before
you know you never [__] know man you
never goddamn name how was the game last
night i didn't even catch like caught
like three minutes of it
it was a good game i mean they just uh
you know the patriots only threw three
passes the whole game the quarterback
was two for three for 16 yards and they
handed off
like 47 times
it was [__] freezing up there in
buffalo new york
and the win was crazy so it was tough to
pass and belichick just said we're just
going to keep running it i got to tell
you i almost moved to buffalo for a
split second
i was thinking about buffalo then i
thought about the [__] winters and
i'm like nah
that's real up there and now even this
everybody's complaining about social
climate it's changing that [__] never
changes in buffalo if you like penguins
that's the [__] place to be that's it
that [__] gets cold up there
if you've seen a movie buffalo 66 you
never want to move there
it's a great movie when he goes home and
they think i love that movie where the
[__] is vincent gala
did he just [__] get himself out of
hollywood or something i think so
because he didn't care like he was doing
a thing on his website where for like um
like five grand or ten grand i forget
what the number was he'll fly to another
country and you could [__] him like for
women
like if you want to [__] me i'll come to
france but you gotta give me a first
class ticket and like 10 grand it was on
his website
he was advertising i'm like that's great
that's tremendous
i know i wonder that guy is not in the
business no more that's [__]
he was a great actor he was a great
writer that guy was just one of those
forces
but i don't think you know people can't
deal with that [__] on a set for long he
was in hollywood like he he went on
howard stern and talked about buffalo 66
and he just the stuff he was saying he
wished cancer on uh roger ebert remember
cisco and ebrick were the movie critics
they said it was like the brown bunny
that movie made was the worst movie ever
in film history he's like i want cancer
on you so bad he's saying on the radio
he said christina ricci all she did was
eat pizzas
on the set
we were over budget because all the food
she was eating it was just great he was
definitely not made for hollywood
no some people are not he's definitely
not i haven't seen him in years
years i haven't seen that [__] dude
so i don't know what happened to him him
i'll tell you who's gone i didn't think
he was gone that [__] great little
actor
he got canceled for beating up his
girlfriend
and he denied it whatever his name is
the crazy [__] guy that was in that
much with brad pitt with the tank
he used to
no he grew up at the comedy store doing
stand-up his father was a biker
and they used to take him to the comedy
store when he was like seven or eight
really good [__] actor i forget
what's going on in your world brother
[__] the acting yeah
uh not much man i got you know comedy
special coming out i'm excited you know
it took like two two and a half years to
do
you know you work that material
and then when you're done with it you're
done with it you dump it off and you
start from scratch again
it's crazy how the special
industry works you know we were coming
up in comedy it was real hard to get a
[__] special you got like two
specials a year
and then five years ago everybody was
doing [__] specials and now netflix
is tightening their [__]
they're not gonna hire anybody crazy you
know and
so the alternative for people who don't
know is
sometimes to just shoot your own special
guys it's at the end of the day it's the
best [__] thing you'll do as long as
you keep the cost low
your hollywood agents will tell you that
your special cost it needs to cost three
to four hundred thousand
for you to sell it and nine out of ten
times you won't [__] sell it so there
you're stuck with this and you told your
mother to refinance the house because
you had a lock
and now you're stuck with the special
i'll tell you the way to do it is maybe
spend a couple grand put it on youtube
charge a couple dollars for it and
you'll be better off you have peace of
mind
unless you're one of the big guys and
they're gonna tell you everything you do
is fantastic that we love that joke you
know they tell you everything unless
you're one of the big guys you know and
but the way to really go
to really blow up now i'm just looking
at what shane did
shane gillis just putting a special
on youtube and let the [__] pieces
fall when they make get it monetized you
make a couple dollars
and let everybody see it you'll get a
million people on there you know five
dollars people don't give a [__] people
know we're trying to put life together
so five dollars aren't gonna make nobody
or break nobody so it's good
yeah you do like you know please put
donations underneath people's donations
just because you put it out there for
free everybody watches stuff on their
phone anyway it's better to own and
you're going to get more views and eyes
on your special if you put it for free
on youtube whether behind the amazon
prime paint wall which like three of my
standard specials are back there
you know some i don't know how many
people rent it or buy it but for free on
youtube you're gonna get a lot more
people watching and that's ultimately
what you want and if you shoot it low
low cost like i did got a good deal and
done it it's it's all good and you want
to own your stuff you want to own
your your your material because you
never know down the road if you can
resell it whatever
you know uh royalties and all that other
stuff i know you had some problem with
an old special it's better like looking
back
we didn't know at that time to own your
stuff we didn't you didn't have the
balls to do it but now it's like why
would you let anyone else own your stuff
at all there's no reason unless you get
netflix and they go hey we're going to
give you 5 million for a special of
course you go no problem you're giving
me 5 million i'll come up with another
hour of material
quick
for 5 million i'll give you a [__]
i'll give you
an hour and two weeks i'll say [__] you
never [__] heard before i speak in
tongues i kill a chicken
at this point i don't give a [__] but
it's
i really like what's going on right now
i really enjoy this even if i'm not
doing comedy i'm happy for the comic
because the comic
doesn't need to depend on hollywood
anymore you're seeing this they don't
even want us in hollywood anymore
because
one night we might go out and swap spit
with a chubby chick and then you know
she's gonna say it was sexual harassment
so half those people don't want to be in
business with us anymore
so now we have to do everything from a
to z
and i'll tell you i want to thank the
pioneers that were you know shane gillis
people before that rich voss yourself
you know you took matters into your own
hands hollywood's not gonna help you i'm
telling you i love when people like
have you been on audition lately and
they're like nah i'm like have you
stayed on your agent nah i really don't
call them what the [__] do you expect
that's why you only get three
goddamn auditions a year so you always
got to be bothered there's nothing like
being in somebody else's hands to help
you
and with comedy you could just help
yourself now from shooting specials to
doing podcasts i was telling somebody
like oh i'm waiting for i shot 30
podcasts and i'm waiting for a network
to pick you up or you might as well wait
till [__] san gennaro's day because
nobody's going to pick you up
just shoot it and put it out yourself on
youtube and cut the drama these people
think that
everybody's going to rewrite the podcast
oh my podcast is going to be great i'm
going to have smoke and mirrors listen
people want to download and listen to
[__] work if you think they're
sitting there watching your light fires
and [__] they'll do that at night they
don't give a [__] but the point is
comics have the world by the balls you
don't need nobody anymore
it's great man actually louie's the one
who really started it
charging five dollars for a special that
he shot at like the beacon theater just
on my website gives me five bucks so you
know i don't want you to steal it you
could just get you know please don't
steal just pay five bucks and he really
started that whole movement of just
owning your thing
and putting it out yourself like i know
jim brewer's got a new comedy special
out he's got it on his patreon page
where if you're a patreon member you can
watch it
right now so yeah just help me be your
own boss look at this at this point in
our careers like why the [__] do we want
to listen to anybody
you know that's why we got into comedy
not to listen to anybody not to have a
boss not to have to have a day job not
to do it
so now we're at the point where you
don't have to listen to anybody it's
[__] great
you know i'm just happy
i got ripped off a ton we all did you
know they they pay you
five cents a minute you get your album
and then they [__] release it and
then they don't tell you where it's
getting released and they don't have
accounting and we don't get a dime i got
ripped off close to ten times in my
[__] life over stupidity
that looking back now i should have just
shot it myself i would have got more
traction and i would have had the main
thing that you said you own it
and you control it look at motley crue
they sold their [__] body of work
last week for 135 million dollars you
won't see those [__] no more
the guy is almost dead the guitarist
he's like weakened at bernie's they just
brought him with like a mask on he don't
even talk no more they put his hand up
they picked his hand up they put a check
in there and they [__] wheeled them
away i mean you'll never see them
anymore that's it they cashed in the
check if that chubby little singer fell
off the stage a month ago before that
135 million wait till you see him next
time dawg that goo that dude's just
gonna fall in the hospital and they're
just gonna fly him to colombia and end
it that's all they need to do with him
just put him in a hotel carter jenna
give him some blow give him some
cocktails and he's [__] done little
chubby singer
it's amazing though a lot of the artists
are doing that yet so they're going to
get like 35 million a piece between the
four guys
why why wouldn't you take that deal
you know you don't want now a lot of
these guys the old artists are selling
their catalog
you know for whatever money for millions
or whatever because they don't want
their estate or their kids to be in this
mess 10 15 years from now when they're
gone
where all these companies you know
record labels screwing with them and
like i forget it it's gonna be too much
aggravation they'd rather say sell a
catalog now for a lump sum d snyder from
twisted sister just did it
but um bob dylan did it bob dylan
stevie nicks did it
yeah just so now that there's no problem
in the you know when they're dead and
gone for their family members whoever
they want to set up their kids this is
the money and that's all you're getting
no more money is coming in because i
sold all that which makes it easier for
them for them
later on in life so
yeah some it's really crazy
with all the things that people are
[__] doing now especially comics that
where if you really want a job as a
comic
you have the world by the balls i know
for a fact brian morton at the new york
comedy club when he got that job the
first thing he did was install cameras
at the comedy club so comics could have
their sets
that's very [__] big remember you
remember when somebody called you and
said hey i'll hire you for the
for the [__] funny bone in virginia
but you got to have a set uh uh a tape
and you're like i don't have a [__]
and then you got to make a tape so you
got to hire somebody for the small 50 to
follow you around he's a [__] pain he
ass he smells like a billy goat you got
to put him in the back of the club he's
a [__] nightmare he gets there late
so and then he tapes and then somebody
the the set is rocking you're you're
seeing money and also some lady
[__] heckles you so now you got to
tape a whole nother [__] set not with
this you just go to brian morton's five
nights in a row
and you got yourself a 20-minute set by
[__] friday and it's great i think
that's a [__] great idea if i ever
got into comedy again i wrote the things
that i would do differently
and i'd really like to tape every
[__] set and watch it
i never did that
i couldn't record them i yeah i it's
tough looking at yourself right i can't
stand the sound or the look of me it
disgusts me so
i want to do that again i think that's a
that's a real
way to really progress in your comedy
fast
like you get good fast by watching your
tapes rewriting i didn't do that [__] i
would write watch the big tapes but
during the week those are the tapes you
need to watch when you're working on
that material
to see where your hand gestures go
things like that you know whatever
yeah no you're right i mean uh look
everybody you know yeah at the new york
comedy club you could cut those clips up
put it on your instagram build a
following like that you put some funny
clips out there
you know and that's what the comics are
doing it's great that you could just
promote yourself and don't have to worry
about the industry comedy central wants
nothing to do with you
hp you don't want nothing to do with
them
right on the other hand you don't want
to do a comedy center what they're going
to do put you on south park what are
they going to do now they got nothing
[__] left over there they've been
making bad [__] decisions for 20
years now they're left with nothing even
daniel tosh abandoned ship
what are they left with
crank cactus yeah cranky as well
they did bring that back yeah they
brought it back because they got nothing
else thank god thank god you get to make
a little doe because they're being
[__] lazy [__] that they are i
mean where would you shoot a special now
with
right now in the next two years on
netflix you're gonna see comic specials
that you've never heard of yeah they're
gonna have their
their chapelles and their [__] uh
uh felipes and the tom seguras and all
that the bert christ is obviously doing
a comedy
uh festival in l.a
myself and jim have not been invited who
gives a [__]
you know what i'm saying i wonder why i
wonder why you know i don't i never
really
when they had it last year they reached
out and they were like this is the
number with the figure
[__] you i know what the figure is you
want to take 10 off the top
nah just so i could be in your festival
first off last time i checked it's my
[__] festival you know what i'm
saying this is the joey diaz [__]
festival you guys are out with your
[__] handout i i jimmy got to the
point that i couldn't even
deal with it anymore like that
the [__] that they come up with i'm like
i can't i don't even know what you're
talking about
i'd rather sit home and [__] rot
rotted that then put up with these
[__] communistic rules
stand-up was for [__] gangsters that
didn't want to do [__] that's what
stand-up is about stand-up is for
[__] lenny bruce when i read that
book
that was who the [__] i was i wanted to
sling dick do coke and do comedy
things change you can't do coke forever
you get a family so then you got to move
on do i still want to do stand-up i
don't [__] know right now but
i know i don't want to get in on a big
situation ever again i'm gonna just do
small things i like small things it's
more intimate
i see these arenas i don't i've never
seen
anything good at a [__] arena
you know like i've never
felt great at an arena
i like theaters i like intimate settings
you know but
the stand-ups 200 seats is no money you
know
we got to expand our [__] horizons
but who gives a [__] yeah you excited
about this special buddy
yeah i'm excited man because it's been a
while and um
yeah just getting rid of it and i love
working on a whole new set and starting
from scratch i always like that
yeah i'm out there i'm thinking i'm
going to this open mic i'm going here
i'm going there i'm just working on i'm
building and it's starting to build you
know little little by little but
i like that i i need to be creative i
need to do something i need to put
something out there and just work the
mind i just can't do the same set over
and over again and the same whatever so
i get to me it motivates me
it's tough to see a comic one year and
then you go see him 18 months later
and he does the same material it drives
me crazy and then they'll complain to
you after the show nothing's happening
for me what you got you still got that
[__] violin joke
from 20 [__] years ago that's not
helping your cause guy you got to switch
it up a little bit people see that you
have to stay i mean for me
i got like 90 days with a [__] joke
and then i got to do something with it i
can't keep going up there saying the
same [__] joke you add a tag say it
backwards that's how i do it and i
you get more stuff when you change the
joke up anyway
yeah but that [__] enough of keeping
your material like it's a museum i can't
do that
no i get bored with it and then the
crowd can sense you're bored with it
because you're not giving it the same
delivery
you did in the beginning and i could
tell all of a sudden it slowly stops
working
you know the jokes are working really
well so it's like all right i got to put
them on the shelf for a while
well that's where music comes up like
we go see uh
ozzy osbourne tomorrow he's gonna do
paranoid
he's gonna do
war pigs
the gift that those guys have is making
that song sound like it's the first time
they're playing it
and that's the same gift that we have as
comics that you got to go out there
it's it's [__] mind-boggling when you
see a comic destroy even improvise
and then you come back and see him two
nights later and he's doing the exact
same material the improv he sold me that
this was the first time
he said this joke
it's [__] brilliant you know so
there's a way of doing it but
after a while when you say that joke
over and over you lose enthusiasm over
it you just you know really lose it so
and the audience doesn't really want to
hear the same material twice like unlike
a band where they only want to hear
they'll go to the bathroom on the new
song
off the van halen record like i don't
want to hear this i don't notice that's
when they'll go get a beer as a as a
comic you they hear the same set like i
already know those jokes
yeah i heard them already
which is good and bad for us it makes us
work harder you know but then again you
know a band knows they could play
madison square garden journey and play
15 of their hits and every song is going
to go over they already know that going
in
yeah i can't as a comic myself before i
got into i always tell people i never
really
saw live comedy which i wasn't i wasn't
a fan of live comedy one i wasn't a fan
of anything i was a fan of doing coke
and watching bands and getting my dick
sucked i was never a fan of nothing
and a buddy of mine won tickets for that
comic from boston like you know
maybe a year before i got locked up and
i went to see him
and he was funny i laughed my ass off
and i remember three years later going
to see him again he bought tickets this
time because he was a big fan i forget
the guy's name
and the guy did the exact same [__]
material and as i was walking out with
him his name is manny he lives in point
pleasant
as i was walking out with him i even
looked at myself that was not good and
he goes no he was great i go he did the
same jokes
as three years ago at that time i had no
college no
comedy knowledge whatsoever i didn't
know what was going on in comedy
but i said to him i go if i ever was a
comic
i wouldn't do the same material like i
just knew it even then before i got into
comedy it bothered me so i just moved on
where'd you shoot the special that was
the connecticut one yeah fairfield
connecticut at the fairfield theater you
got the bus you got all the boys on the
bus drinking farting
yeah we had a party bus go up like 30 of
my friends and family and stuff took the
bus up there don jameson opened up
warmed up the crowd did a great job and
yeah 30 animals from my town you know
took the bus up there i think i made
them sure they came to the early show
you know i did two shows of one night
come because they're gonna be drunk so
come to the seven o'clock show i don't
want you guys at the nine o'clock
because you're going to be yelling
you'll be the one heckling my family and
friends
and drunk like already my nephew was
sleeping during my set
he drank so much he was out cold he
watched he saw he goes i remember the
first 10 minutes that i fell asleep
in my chair and i was at like you know 7
40 when i went on
jesus
so i knew
just you know bringing the early show
but it's good because they always want
to call my own you know they've seen me
a million times my family and friends so
i just
pick uh special occasions for them to
come out
and come see me so that was that would
you know usually they'll come to the
tapings if they're in the area if i
don't do it down in florida or something
like that but the last couple specials
been around the area so they've come
i love it that you uh
you had a [__] you you put together a
crew of [__]
your best buddies they got a keg
and you went up there four hours you had
to call them because there was traffic
you know i was still [__] sick i
would have gone up with those savages
just to
just to see the inside and smell the
inside of that bus
well the one guy my one friend tony
brought a
milk jug an empty milk jug to piss in on
the bus
because he knew he was going to be
drinking a lot of beer and there was no
there was no bathroom on the bus
so he's like i'm prepared i got my empty
jug if i got to go because he didn't
want the bus driver to stop and then one
of the
one of my nephew mike's friends had a
piss and he tony made him doing him in
the jug the boss upon everybody
i'm surprised they even brought the
[__] jug and didn't just piss on the
[__] floor my friends were just
pissed on the [__] floor those were
the worst days of my life i gotta tell
you
when i would come home and i had a group
of friends that were buckwild and they'd
come to the shows
and one night they came to rascals
and uh whatever the [__] the main one
not the shore
west orange west orange and one of my
buddies got so hammered on the quaalude
he just fell
at the bar he was under the chair and
[__] we couldn't find him for like 10
minutes like where is he
we had to go behind there where he was
standing and look and he was down on the
couch that was constantly
they embarrassed me in like new york
at stand-up new york maybe 20 years ago
the whole crew came
and two of my friends came that were
undercover cops
and they had their badges on their thing
and they were laying on the bar and you
could see how coked up they were they
were [__] jawing jimmy like jordan
[__] white rings on their nose and i
go to the bathroom i come out and the
guy's got his hand on his waist and you
can see the gun and the badge and i'm
like dog
you can't let these guys know you're a
cop look at the [__] shape of you
he's like
i'm like put the [__] gun away give
me the badge and after and as i was
leaving the guy from stand-up new york
goes hey your friends are always welcome
here i'm like share they look at the
[__] shape of them i would beg them
don't do coke at the club
i would be like the fifth one up and
they would do coke and then they'd start
talking
and by the time i got up there they
would be yelling and [__] i can't do it
i can't they don't show up anymore thank
god they stopped that [__] you got i you
always have to remind them say listen
this is my work i'm bringing you my work
please behave
they don't get it though they don't
think it's work for some reason like if
i showed up at your work and started
causing problems
and doing shots and screaming everybody
walking by yelling at him wouldn't you
be like what are you doing that's what
you're doing you're doing my special my
one friend tony you know tony
i told i knew where they were sitting
the whole row we came like the third row
my whole family so going over security
detail before the show i said like
there's gonna be a guy sitting in that
third row right over here he's gonna be
a problem but leave him alone he'll be
fine he's just happy he might yell a
couple things out but he'll so just
don't kick him out because he's a friend
of mine but he's definitely going to be
a problem
and then my manager tommy goes up and
and says hey we're filming a
comedy special here tonight i just want
to let you guys know i appreciate it
please don't heckle when jim's on stage
we're filming this and all this stuff he
goes if you have anything you want to
just yell out just yell it out now and
get it out of your system so my friend
tony yells to my my manager tommy show
me your tits
[Laughter]
people will never understand the
mentality
of the jersey rat no you're never real
i'm a jersey rat you'll never
you can live like i get it but if i
brought somebody in here from like
chicago and they saw my friends in
action and [__] like that it wouldn't be
a fun situation and you i don't get
embarrassed with my friends i just don't
bring nobody around them
that's that that's it when they're
around i want them around by themselves
to their own
i can't mix and match with people no no
because they're
because you don't want to censor them
like this is who they are i'm not going
to tell them hey behave but so you just
know where you pick your spots
where you can bring yourself answer your
friends anyway no you don't that is the
most ridiculous thing in the world i
could never
censor my friends i could act you know
like again i love these jersey rats and
my gift growing up
was to feed the rats
what does that mean to get them going
if i knew somebody who [__] went off
when he did blow and drank i would take
him to the bar
feed him coke and feed him shots every
two [__] minutes because i couldn't
wait
for him to go off that was what my night
was based on
him going off i have a friend roger
holloway god bless his soul he's been
dead a year i didn't get this when i
i've been back a year and a half didn't
even get to see him before he died but
when i went out with him i knew he loved
coke
and i lose i knew that people would say
hey slow it down with him [__] you
i'm going to double up with him i was
going to buy him a half gram now i'm
going to buy him a gram so he can have
even more so he could [__] all he
use all goddamn night i remember the
first time i went to your basement you
walked me out you're like hey man
i hope those guys didn't offend you and
i was like listen you made my day
because i thought all those type of
people were dead yeah i know that's
right if it was up to the united states
all of us would be dead
who speaks that way would be dead this
is the direction we're going
i mean i don't know if a lot of comics i
don't know if you saw this
and it doesn't when you when you hear it
it doesn't bother you affect you
but if you're a [__] rough comic it
should
[__] they asked
andrew schultz not to do a theater
because they said he was dirty
if if they think andrew schultz is dirty
they're gonna put me under the [__]
jail
i mean jim this is something to think
about that i've been thinking about
since i saw that i go
massey theater canceled
him this is going to be a trend pretty
soon
they don't want us to talk like we do
you know every time rogan says something
a doctor invertment
it's a front page of yahoo and it's like
they say that you did some you know i
spoke about on the podcast the other day
that
they were i haven't read anything else
about it they were going after jeff
garland
for like uh you know if jeff garland is
offensive
i better [__] hang myself right now
i know right
so what these people are going for now
is just
that and i tell you everybody's like
sitting tight listen wait for the
holidays to pass
after the holidays it's gonna be a
[__] the [__] that they're gonna
drop let's look at the look what de
blasio dropped on this yesterday
and that's for new york that's it you
might as well [__] stab that in the
heart
now i can't even bring five and
eleven-year-olds to a [__] thing in
new york city yeah everybody's gotta be
vaccinated all private companies and i'm
sure the guy that replaces him
eric whatever his [__] name is will
change that mandate
when he takes office but you think about
that that's not good guys
that's gonna stick the [__] fork in
new york right there no i know a lot of
you know a lot of people from jersey
bring their kids in
you know they go to dinner they go to a
show or something like that i can't even
bring my kid in to come to the comedy
club because he won't be allowed in
he's 11 years old you know starting like
another week or so it's insane what
you're doing to these businesses and
stuff you know
so yeah just
you know joe says something joe has a
doctor on that doesn't agree with cnn
and and the next day it's all news they
just take these little quotes and go
crazy over it
you know it's it's it really isn't
saying i know they're just
they they're trying to control it and
they can and then you got trump who's
going to start his own like twitter
it's going to start up in like a month
or two
where you can go on there and say
whatever you want basically and they're
already freaking out over they're trying
to see how how they could shut it down
i gotta be honest i kind of miss trump
i kind of miss him even though i didn't
vote for him even though i'm not a
political guy
this [__] that's going on now like i'm
not a political guy i just look at biden
and i know that's a mistake and pamela
harris she's [__] garbage
she's hot garbage all she could do is
flip a [__] hair up
she's hot [__] garbage and now i tell
you when trump [__] raised his hand
and threw alec baldwin under the bus
that was the happiest day of my life
because i [__] hated baldwin doing
trump
that [__] wasn't funny at [__] all it
wasn't funny at all and those poor
bastards kept bringing it to the table
like it was gonna
kill america the only people who liked
that impersonations were people who
didn't like trump i'm a fan of
impersonations but a bad impersonation
is a bad impersonation
i [__] loved it when trump raised his
hand and said lock him up he's got
mental health issues
to me that was [__] the best day of
my life for [__] trump
meanwhile all those guys were all
friends with trump you know that dinero
and
all these guys alan baldwin they're all
new yorkers they all hung out with them
jay-z
you know trump was the man until he ran
and then all of a sudden they turned on
him and now i've always just
embarrassing with him and his wife on
instagram
going i love you honey no matter what
you support me you got my back i don't
care what happens to my career i just
know i have you you you're a [__] 65
year old man groveling on instagram
to your wife how about you say that to
her [__] face
nobody needs to hear that you're 65
years old i see how you talk to your
wife terry you say if i wasn't to terry
i wouldn't be around you don't put that
on [__] instagram i just want to let
you know terry you tell her right to her
but this is a [__] 65 year old that's
all i need now today they're kissing at
a picture
alec baldwin is white like what are you
trying to do
hollywood
has become
so
[__] pukey
nine days after that that woman died
after he you know shot her on set
they're posting a picture of them as a
family in halloween costumes
alec baldwin his wife and his kids all
in halloween costumes like what are you
doing [__] mental health
that
hollywood does to you you
when i didn't even watch the whole
[__] thing with stephanopoulos
whatever his [__] name is
all i had to do was watch three minutes
of it and then i watched segments of him
going i didn't pull the trigger
he's [__] crying on tv i didn't watch
i didn't pay attention to it i woke up
the next day and pierce morgan is
goofing on him
everybody's [__] goofing on him that
he's a fake and i'm like you know what
guys
why does this shock you they're [__]
actors
all of them all of them are actors they
know how to try to win you over with
[__] for alec baldwin that [__]
didn't [__] work the other day people
saw through that you know hollywood is
just
a puke [__] place now
you look at it and you're like what the
[__] happened
harvey weinstein this that
and then you got [__] alec bowen
saying [__] about george clooney and
george what the [__] does george clooney
know about a [__] gun
i don't know i i just don't know anymore
you see him coming a [__] mile away
and it's just not for me no more
no you always say that i'm so happy to
be out of that lifestyle
you know when the [__] going on in la
and hollywood and all that stuff you're
like i'm just so happy i'm not involved
in that anymore i don't even care
come on man what they did to comics
during the pandemic and now people won't
give those comic specials even though
they got vindicated even though the
comics are [__] decent people and
that was a time ago
you know i told you the other day i go
you know jim i
i'm [__] embarrassed to say this on
any podcast because i've been
lying to people obviously because i told
them it's not like that
you know america does not want to give
you a second chance anymore
there's no more second chances
there used to be second chances in the
50s
the 60s the 70s you know a couple of
them in the 80s michael vick in the 90s
but i got to be honest you look at a guy
like me now and i knew this when i
became a comedian it was the reason i
became a comic jimmy
that i'm not going to be able to ever
get a job i got a pee in a bottle
and i got a [__] police record
hey i brought it upon myself i'm not
sitting here whining or whatever
but what happens to the guy that does go
to jail for 15 years he made a mistake
he comes out he wants to go looking for
a job nobody's gonna hire this guy
you're right absolutely i know they
don't give you a second chance no
someone was just bitching mel gibson's
gonna direct lethal weapon five i guess
and some big director or a producer and
hollywood just wrote a whole piece for
like i know maybe it was the new york
times or something about how could you
hire this guy he aged jews and this is
ridiculous that you're gonna hire him to
direct that movie the guys the mel
gibson paid his price he went away for
like [__] five years in the middle of
his career when that [__] went down
you know back a cop car and all that
stuff so it's like the guy paid so he
can't come back
you know that was 20 years ago you're
still going to hold that against him he
was drunk and he said some [__] in the
back of a cop car
and i'm going to tell you something
that's like somebody calling me a bigot
and it [__] infuriates me when people
don't see it
for what it is let me tell you something
about mel gibson and pete this is again
the first time i've said this on a
podcast
i got the pleasure to work with a guy
named dean
something twice i worked with him on
to boxing more with de niro and i worked
and i'm on the longest job
yard his name is dean something
and it's not hard to find he's like the
third name on the credits he's a big
shot
the guy is a big old australian guy you
know the type jimmy he likes to have a
good time drink couple beers and [__]
well let me tell you what that dude had
dianna doing he won
the oscar for dances with wolves for
being the cinematographer
but
why i fell in love with him is because
he's the real
cinematographer for [__] mad max
and the first road warrior
the road warrior this guy dean
strickland or whatever his name is what
is it
what is it s-e-m-l-e-r simular yeah dean
simler
this [__] every day would talk
to mel gibson on the phone
every day when we were shooting the
longest yard at some part of the day him
and mel there's people that we all talk
to one person two people your brother
dan whatever and you say things
you say cuban jokes you say puerto rican
jokes you say jew jokes you say polak
jokes whatever i know for a fact
every day dean would come up to me on
the phone and he'd go hey
you want to hear this joke and it would
be what you'd call today a tasteless
joke but it would be a funny joke to me
you know like
you know jesus came out of central park
and
there were two catholics on a [__]
rabbi and the two captives were like
look at jesus he'll throw a blessing on
us jesus come here throw a blessing on
me uh my wife has cancer my mother has
cancer jesus like here you know here's a
blessing on you jesus i'm a bishop my
foot hurts uh here's a blessing and the
jews like jesus don't touch me i'm on
disability like those type of jokes
right they don't hurt nobody
they're simple stupid street jokes if
you judge somebody on one of those
street jokes you have a [__] problem
that's what
him and uh
used to do every day mel gibson the
stealth two stupid [__] jokes and i
know that for a fact that the chick from
uh
the chick from uh hannibal stuck up for
him you know dan whatever her name is
jody foster stuck up for him and she's
as jewish as can be
yeah so they're getting the whole
[__] thing wrong but back to your
point yeah you can't
they don't want you to have a second
chance anymore
they do not want it at all i saw the
petitions for mike vick after he came
back and proved himself and went to
therapy they still and i was a little
upset with michael victor those are
[__] dogs but i learned how to give
somebody a check and second chance
because society gave me a second chance
but that's not happening anymore
and he's also been an upstanding citizen
since he's gone out michael vick he has
gotten in any trouble nothing
you know you always think that maybe
he's going to do something again
but he hasn't you know what he's he's on
like he's doing like nfl today or
something like that i saw him on
as like a guest analyst or something or
pregame thing so
you know thank god believe me if that
happened today with the with the thing
he did with the dogs you would never
hear from him again
he'd have to go in hiding
and never come back there's no way a
team would sign him after that no no
look at i saw something last night the
kid who played superfly
the little young brother has over 30
sexual assaults
[__] superfly went freaky
[Laughter]
dirty sexual assault since he shot
[__] superfly you excited about this
special brother i'm excited a lot yeah i
can tell you you've been putting some
hard work into it i know it's going to
be [__] great what's the name of it
it's called bite the bullet uh it's on
youtube my youtube page youtube.com
slash jim florentine comedy comes out
monday december 13th they'll be
available
[__] them just go to florentine comedy
on youtube when it's there and you got
the uh the terrorizing telemarketers i
saw something yesterday
i listened to one of the clips last week
it was [__] hysterical it was oh yeah
you heard a new one oh my god i was
[__] dying the idea at the house
i love all that
torturing people [__] that's right up my
[__] alley
and then you're at the saint louis funny
bone this weekend correct this weekend
yeah friday and saturday friday's
thursday through sunday actually
december 9th
[__] that's a long [__] week miami's
gotta buy
you know sometimes there's some a
certain amount a few clubs around the
country i'll do four days the funny bone
in st louis i love that place i've been
doing it for years matt the manager is
amazing
side splitters in tampa
bt is one of the best clubs in the
country the guy in
the funny stop in cuyahoga falls pete
there's a few that i will do because i
like these guys that much
well man i'll be looking forward for
monday i'll see you uh no i won't even
see you sunday for football holy [__]
yeah yeah i mean goodbye this week but
i'm on my own this [__] weekend
you'll be in st louis your brothers and
[__] the maruba i'm all alone here
in [__] freezing new jersey but hey
man
thank you for taking the time i know you
got a big day today you got to move
around you got an ozzy osbourne uh
ozzie's boneyard probably coming up this
week so thank you for taking the time
jim i appreciate that you always thank
you all right have a great day and i'll
bump into you later hopefully all right
great stay black brother
what up
i hope you enjoyed jimmy he's a great
[__] dude i love him with all my
heart please do me a favor if you're in
the st louis
area this weekend stop by funny bone and
say hello bring him a [__] he don't
smoke reefer but bring him a [__]
album or bring him a led zeppelin
t-shirt or whatever even if it's huge he
don't give a [__] and then monday his
special comes out he's a good dude
he's one of my closest friends i'm very
tight with his family his family is one
of the best families i've been around
and it's a
florentine [__] crime family i
love him to that
i love you guys too thank you very much
for watching the show this week
thank you for [__] giving me all the
negative reviews on drinking water in
your microphone i'm not gonna do it no
more i'm just gonna live here like an
african and be [__]
dehydrated and [__] and talk to you
[__] but i love you guys
thank you very much for watching this
weekend thank you very much for having
my back stay black
i'll see you [__] monday tip
top
[__] magoo
all right i want to thank jimmy
florentine but most importantly i want
to thank you guys for getting the party
started the joint is brought to you by
liquid iv listen
i love ivs i don't like sticking a
needle in my own because i don't like
[__] needles so this is the perfect
product for you
let me tell you something about liquid
iv i know you're going to booze this
season when you wake up in the morning
you want some of the hair of the dog
don't you [__] that get yourself some
liquid iv you add one stick the liquid i
beat the 16 ounces of water and they'll
hydrate you faster and efficiently than
water alone i love the liquid iv like i
said i get a pre-drink before i go to
the gym and then i put one package and
16 ounces i put two for like 30 ounces
for like uh you know the gym and i drink
it while i'm at the gym let me tell you
something it's healthier than those
sugary sports drinks there's no
artificial flavors of preservatives and
it's got less sugar than an apple this
is true they're tremendous let me tell
you something i feel just as good when
i'm leaving the gym as i walk in there
because i'm hydrated i never knew that
so do me a favor get some liquid iv
they're supporting frontline workers to
stay healthy liquid iv has donated to
hospitals food banks and veterans 11
million servings donated and counting
it's made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan gluten free dairy free and soy
free i got you covered guys this is
tremendous this is the way to start your
new year off so the listeners of the
joint grab your favorite liquid iv
flavors nationwide at walmart or get
them delivered like i do get 25
off when you get it go to liquidive.com
and use promo code joey at checkout so
again go to liquidity.com promo code
joey at checkout that's 25
off anything you order get better
hydration today using promo code joey at
liquid iv the joint is brought to you by
cbd lion
the best the goods i've been with him
for three four years
two surgeries
you know i'm an old [__] man i go to
jiu jitsu i got a tape on my knees
but listen whether you go with the tape
the kinesiology tape the back ball the
the cream the gummies
if you smoke the reefer they'll put it
into your lungs they'll put it into your
body one way or another so do me a favor
go to cbdlion.com and look at the third
party lab results you're gonna freak out
this ain't no gas station guy this ain't
no swami from salami this is uncle joey
coming to you direct with some cbd line
pressing code joey and get 20
off your first order delivered right to
your [__] house all right who's
better than cbd lion
nobody
cbd lion ko joey and the joint is
brought to you by
draftkings one of my favorite companies
ever listen i love them with all my
heart i trust them they're safe secure
and reliable
you could draw your money whenever you
want and then the number one sports book
around their major partners with nfl nba
ufc draftkings is here to make sure
you have
a green christmas
new customers can bet one dollar on any
team to score and 100 and free bets is
that simple you'll be a winner with just
one point scored
i love i love draftkings for multiple
reasons most importantly i got great
lines and i have fun when i gamble and
they have a social network so we could
[__] have a tattei on there now a
sports pick isn't available in your
state draftkings won't leave you
empty-handed everyone can play huge cash
prizes all season long with draftkings
daily fantasy sports contest draftkings
has given all new customers a free shot
at millions of dollars in total prizes
for their first deposit so do me a favor
download the draftking sportsbook app
today right now use promo code joey
j-o-e-y throw down one dollar on any
team to score
one point and will you win our last in
three bets if they score
you score with promo code joey this week
at draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nfl now
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania colorado west
virginia new customers only
minimum five hour deposit one dollar
wager one per customer restrictions
apply see draftkings.com
books for details now if you got a
gambling farm i want you to take a
little breather call 1-800 gamble but if
not let's get this [__] party started
jack and let's win some money
santa needs some [__] guinness you
need getters mama needs getters
draftkings.com
joey i want to thank draftkings
i want to thank cbd line i want to thank
liquid iv
for having my back this week but most
importantly i want to thank you [__]
savages and jim florentine i love you
have a great weekend stay black and i'll
be back monday tip top magoo
so
[Music]
you